what's going on guys this is rob and we
got our very first episode of marvel
what if and i gotta say i loved it oh my
god i absolutely loved it and if this is
an indication of what this series is
going to be like going forward i'm only
more excited it happened really fast but
here's the funny thing the series felt
exactly like a what if comic that's how
the word of comics play out right they
happen like that they they take place so
quickly like it opens up exactly the way
a what-if comic would which is here's
how things played out as you know them
but what if they happen differently
right just one choice one decision one
different thing changes everything i
love the idea that like steve rogers was
shot and injured i love the idea that
abraham erskine still died and i love
that peggy carter went on to become like
the new captain america when she took
the super soldier's serum everything got
bigger
everything
got bigger
but it was a cool episode i absolutely
loved it
[Laughter]
you know honestly there's not a lot to
go on here in terms of like creating
theories or anything like that but there
are a few things that caught my mind one
of which is actually kind of
disappointing so the first thing and
really probably the question that a lot
of people have is like what's the deal
with the watcher okay so tomorrow we
will have a video coming out with the
origins and powers of the watcher right
so i'll explain that whole thing those
guys who don't know the origins and
power series is something that i started
on comics explained something like six
or seven years ago and then i replaced
it with a new series and so i'm just
gonna transition it over here to geek
culture explained and just do it here
right if it's better it's just more of a
confined and condensed version of what
we already do at comics explain but with
regards to the watcher himself if we
want to give you guys like the really
really skinny one the whole purpose of
the watcher is to literally just monitor
alternate realities and he does this
from a place called the blue area of the
moon which is a portion of earth's moon
that actually has oxygen and not just
the watcher uses that a lot of other
people use it right the x-men have
stayed there for a while the inhumans
which nobody cares about have stayed
there for a while different people have
gone there there's been huge battles
that have taken place in the blue area
of the moon largely because earth was a
big staging ground between the war of
the cree and the scrolls and whoever
took earth would basically win the war
because it was like when the allied
forces took the beaches of normandy
during world war ii you know what i mean
just this is a strategic location across
the entirety of the universe with
regards to this war and also because
earth is so powerful so if you can
conquer earth you can control the people
and if you control the people well then
you have an insanely just massively
powerful army at your disposal we saw
them try to do that during the events of
maximum security when earth got turned
into a prison planet the important thing
here
[Laughter]
is that with regards to how the how the
watcher was portrayed here it was great
i loved the way the watcher looked he
looked a lot more like i would expect
eternity to look from the from from in
in the marvel cinematic universe really
begs the question what's eternity going
to look like but the watcher looked cool
but i loved the whole thing the story
progressed exactly the way that i would
expect it to with uh with peggy carter
becoming uh you know captain america
that i guess really you know captain
carter the whole plot of captain america
the first avenger just kind of playing
out essentially the same way but with a
couple few a couple differences here and
there bucky barnes basically surviving i
did love those little things right we're
like literally bucky barnes instead of
falling off the train just gets grabbed
by captain carter and brought on top so
obviously bucky does not go on to become
the winner soldier but there are some
cool moments here now one of the big
questions a lot of people i imagine are
asking is what's the deal with hydra
stomper does hydra stomper exist in the
comics the answer to that question is no
if anything hydra stomper is a reference
to steve rogers when he had his time as
the head of hydra and secret empire
because he was called the stomper at
that time he was more of a stomper of
anybody who wasn't part of hydra and it
was kind of crazy how he was able to
pull it off but it's really more of a
reference to that but it's still a cool
concept and i absolutely loved it having
said that once you start to get towards
the end of the movie i think that's
where a lot of questions come into play
with regards to the if series
specifically the ending of it right that
great big huge giant monster that showed
up that was basically summoned by the
red skull and then ultimately ended up
killing it what was that okay i see a
lot of people saying that it was
shumagorath and admittedly when i saw
the previews i thought it was
shumagorath until we saw its mouth and
that's how we know it's not shumagorath
so here's the thing shumogorath is what
we refer to as a mini angled one or a
great old one or something like that
technically he comes from the place
between universes but he is part of a
race that's immensely powerful now
unlike the other members of the many
angled ones that just kind of stay
confined between universes schuma gorath
has made his way into other universes
and conquered entire universes
subjugated entire universes so they all
bend their allegiance to schuma gorath
now shubo gorath himself when he appears
is telepathic and so if that was
shumogorath you would have heard him
speak right you would have heard like
his voice either he would have like
seized control of the red skull and
spoke through the red skull or you would
have just heard us they all would have
just heard his voice in their heads
right and that would have been it like i
am schumer gorath i am here to basically
conquer this reality and none of you can
stop me blar yada yada yada you know
comic book talk like that's basically
what would have happened right instead
like this thing just roared at them was
just this insane roar that literally
deafened the place like steve rogers in
his amazing hydro stomper suit had to
get them out of there
in order to keep them alive and then
peggy carter basically sacrificed your
life by pushing the thing right back
through the portal again that is most
likely just your average one of the mill
mini angled one but there are other
possibilities here so if you go and look
at marvel comics and you look at new
avengers vol 3 issues 19 20 and 21 this
was part of a story that dealt with
something called the incursions which
was basically the collapse of the
multiverse and there was a point when
doctor strange and the rest of the
illuminati ended up traveling to an
alternate reality that was home to what
was in effect marvel's version of the
justice league of america from dc comics
and a great big huge battle in suit
because of the fact that the illuminati
were basically getting crushed dr
strange revealed that he had traveled to
a place called the center's market which
is basically where you can barter
portions of your soul for all different
kinds of things what doctor strange
wanted to do was barter 100 of his soul
for 100 of power basically making him
god he didn't have complete soul so he
basically couldn't make a bargain with
the resolute throne this basically led
to him going back to the sanctum
sanctorum and digging out this old book
that was really just a dark black magic
book it's worse than the dark hole if
you can believe that right like no good
ever comes out of reading this book and
what he learned in that book was used in
his battle with the great society when
he basically opened up a dimensional
portal and this giant tentacle monster
started you know entering into that
plane of existence and then basically
started killing the great society that
that version of the justice league and
mobile comics now the big difference
between that creature as we saw it and
what you saw here is that creature was
actually sucking the life force out of
the great society right we didn't really
see that here it was just a giant
tentacle monster that was wrapping its
you know arms around people and
destroying them and throwing them into
stuff and all that kind of stuff so it
looks like it's just your average
run-of-the-mill mini angled one having
said that that's still a big deal
because we know that like america chavez
and doctor strange too america chavez
has the ability to hop from one
dimension to the next right to literally
jump between universes we know just why
the leaks and supposed stories that are
going on out there that uh america
chavez is going to play an important
role in doctor strange too because
schumacher is chasing after her but
again this might just be one of those
things where marvel's just kind of
easing us into this idea of just
dimensional beings out there the other
thing is it could just be a random
dimensional being right this could be
just a random monster right that that
somewhere along the line that red skull
learned about this demonic entity uh
just by looking at information that was
out there studying the world tree of
idrisil is what it looked like he was
looking at was basically the world tree
of idracial and realizing that a person
with a tesseract could actually access
all those different locations and then
in turn just summon this demonic looking
entity right this giant tentacle monster
now that does bet the question how is
red skull able to do that in the first
place okay so here's how the tesseract
works and it's comparison to uh marvel
comics so in marvel comics the tesseract
is actually a cosmic cube it's basically
just the energy of these insanely
powerful beings called the beyonders
confined into a cube that's really all
it is in the marvel cinematic universe
it's literally just the space stone
right just allows you to open up portals
to dimensional places and things like
that from one dimension to the next the
only real involvement that we've seen it
used for is to actually open up portals
in space so that loki for example could
summon the tatari army from the other
part of the universe directly to their
location and then essentially launch the
invasion of new york but the way that uh
interdimensional travel works the way to
open portals and mobile comics is if you
can open a portal from one side of the
universe to the other you can open a
portal between dimensions and all of
these these dimensions exist in the
singular universe now if you look at
something like asgard for example you
guys know you have the bifrost right
like literally this bifrost bridge that
opens up and then like thor appears
right that's basically just an access
way right it's opening a door it's
really all it is places like asgard
places like yotenheim places like uh
niflheim different things like that you
can only access those if you have the
power to open dimensional barriers you
can't necessarily fly there i don't know
how it is that they explain that in the
marvel cinematic universe with them
basically flying to that giant space
station or that giant weapons
manufacturing plant right i mean it was
kind of weird to fly into davalier but
nonetheless you know that's not normally
how it's supposed to happen but the mcu
is doing its own thing that's in effect
what happened in this right that the
space stone can be used for more than
just opening portals that allow a person
to travel from one side of the universe
to the other instantaneously wormholes
if that's what you want to call it
instead you can actually open barriers
to other dimensions this is a huge
revelation because it really expands on
what we've seen the space stone doing
but the important thing here is this
offers a lot of expansion right if you
know where to look there's some big
differences that are going on here a lot
of a lot of information being given to
us but as for the particular ending
right that giant tentacle monster that
just looks like a mini angled one right
nothing too special about that just a
mini angled one being that exists
between dimensions or possibly even in a
dimension itself that was just summoned
by you know someone by the red skull and
that was basically it but the one thing
that disappointed me about this right so
one thing that i was hoping for more
than anything in this episode the one
thing that was the biggest
disappointment to me is that we did not
get to see captain carter inducted into
the captain britain corps it would have
been the perfect time to do it right it
would have been the perfect time to do
it and it could have just been a
post-credits scene right it literally
could have been one of these things
where like the episode ends with with
peggy carter coming back 70 years after
she was sucked into the portal which is
essentially identical with steve rogers
except she wasn't frozen in ice and then
like as a post-credit scene because of
the fact that she literally displayed
this insane level of courage by being
willing to sacrifice her life in order
to save her reality that suddenly merlin
and roma appear and they're like you've
been chosen to become part of the
captain britain corps please select the
amulet of right or the sword of mine and
she chooses the amulet boom peggy
carter's a captain britain it would have
been awesome it would have been
absolutely amazing just a great
post-credits scene the reason why that
matters is the captain britain core is
like the green lantern corps from dc
comics except they protect the
multiverse instead of a singular
universe i have a video on comics
explained that'll explain the whole
captain of written core to you if you're
interested about that but i'm
disappointed that we didn't get to see
that i felt like it would have been a
great expansion the biggest issue that
you would have with that though is that
if it's not part of the grand plan of
what it is they're trying to do that in
effect they would have thrown peggy
carter into the captain written core and
then done nothing with it right which
wouldn't have made a whole lot of sense
that being said the great thing about
the what if stories is that one we've
been told by brad winderbaum one of the
executives over at marvel is we could
see future movies or series based on
stuff that we're seeing in the what if
story and so it's entirely possible that
with everything going on in doctor
strange too the multiverse of madness
and the fact that the multiverse is just
kind of run amok the captain britain
core is formed in the aftermath of that
and then we circle right back around to
this what if series and then peggy
carter is brought into the captain
britain corps but i really think it
would have been cool to have that in the
mcu but with that being said guys let me
know what your thoughts were on episode
one did you love it did you hate it did
you think it was yeah let me know what
you guys think thank you all for
watching and i will catch you all later
peace